adam is going to start us off in
milwaukee wisconsin hi adam what's up
hi dave how you doing better than i
deserve man how can i help
well right now i just turned 19 years
old
um and i did what every 18 year old does
you know you start uh
you know you're eligible to get credit
cards everything like that
and so i got a car loan and then i also
got credit cards
totaling about 13k um
and i just started uh i cancelled all my
subscriptions last night you know
and i'm starting baby steps but i'm just
wondering how to stay motivated during
baby steps
uh well i mean there's a lot of things
that motivate you fear is one of them
um yeah obviously being wealthy would be
one of them
and um this 13 000 is is smacking you
around in the back of your head you got
that
that nasty taste on the back of your
tongue called regret right
yeah you know i'm not going to do that
again yeah but yeah so what do you make
what's your income
uh so right now i'm making about 32k i
was making about 42k
last year but i got laid off due to
covid so you're working 40 hours
and yeah i'm working full-time right now
um i would like to get in a higher paid
career as well but i just don't have
motivation for school i mean i did
terrible in high school
um you know i'm i'm very intelligent but
i just don't have the motivation that's
what i lack
you know okay
well i mean you don't have motivation to
do higher ed that's not a problem but
you're gonna have to have my motivation
to do something right yeah and you know
otherwise we would question your comment
about intelligence
yeah i agree with you there okay there's
gotta be something to get you fired up
yeah you know i mean i'll get like a
hobby and i'll keep it for a bit you
know but then i just lose track of it
and i feel you know that's
how i classify school schooling as well
okay
well i mean the thing is this the bible
says where there is no vision
the people perish they die and so you
need a vision for something that's
big bold and noble that you're going to
work your butt off towards
um and that way you have what we call
purpose uh you're useful
at that point you're adding value at
that point as far as
13 000 goes what i would do is pretty
simple i'd pick up like three extra jobs
delivering pizzas uber eats and mowing
grass whatever you're only working 40
hours that's not much
uh and you're broke so uh time to fix
that the way you fix broke is you go get
some money
and here's the trick you can make an
extra 3 000 a month and be done with
this whole thing in about three or four
months
but you're going to get geared up about
it
you can wander into dead honey but you
can't wander out
you got to get wired up and fired up and
that's the only way you're going to do
it
so if i were in your shoes i would be a
little bit scared a little bit mad at
myself for having dug this hole
and uh a little bit excited about my
future and this crap standing between me
and awesomeness in my future
so we're gonna knock it out knock it in
the head smack it
and so but you know you
get with it let's get some extra income
coming in plus where are you spending
the 32 grand you're 19
where could it possibly go except going
out to eat dates and bar hopping or
whatever
so stop it sit at home well you don't
need to sit at home you ain't got time
to go spend any money because you're
working all the time now
uh you ain't time to spend money all you
are is at work
and go do that for about four months and
all of a sudden you'll have a little bit
of pile of money and you'll have no debt
at all and it's magical how that'll work
for you
uh but if you lay that down on paper and
you can see
how what i'm talking about works i mean
thirteen thousand divided by three
thousand how fast are we gonna be out
that's four months dude i mean
there you go boom boom and and so
you lay that out you go okay there's my
there's my september
that's where that's what my october
looks like i'll be here by christmas
and um when you lay those things out
laying out a detailed goal like that
that is reachable where the light at the
end of the tunnel is
not an oncoming train maybe that'll get
you moving
i don't know how to motivate someone you
motivate yourself
you discipline yourself but that all has
to do with you having a vision